i knew a few light keepers when there
were all kind of like houses around here
my father-in-law was a lighthouse keeper
on briar island
they started closing them up closing
them up and people just started
disappearing some people went
to other ones and some people just
stopped but i think
this one was offered to a few people
not very many took it so
well i'll get up quarter two in the
morning the nice thing about here is you
step out of bed you're at work
halifax coast guard radio halifax coast
guard radio this is machia seal island
my channel i see you island channel one
nine come in
there's always something to keep you
busy
but you don't have a timetable saying
you have to get up this morning and do
this or you have to do that so you
pretty well pick and choose what you
want to do when you want to do it when
you can handle what it is you're doing
one shift is 2 am to 10 am and the other
shift is 2 in the afternoon until 10 in
the evening
i feel now that
instead of being the keeper of the light
out here you're more of the keeper of
the island
in looking after it
as opposed to just the mechanical
systems that are on
you're only bored out here if you want
to be bored out here
if you're going to be bored out here
you're going to be bored anywhere
you just take a walk outside and look
there's always different birds to see
there's always something different going
on
you know you look around and if it
wasn't for the houses and stuff here you
think it's the same as it was 10 million
years ago
pretty quiet in the winter time
the thrill of being out here in a storm
is nice
you can get some really nice pictures
so
i think one of the nicest things is you
come out here and you just kind of
escape from reality for a while
this is your little piece of reality
you make it whatever you want it to be
you